on that grand scale a human life feels
tiny do you Ponder your own mortality
Are You Afraid Of Death no I'm you know
I I used to be afraid of death um I did
I like my like I remember as a young
person being kind of like very scared of
mortality like didn't want to think
about it and so on and always had a big
and as I've gotten older I'm 59 now as
I've gotten older somehow that fear has
sort of gone away I don't um you know I
I would like to stay alive for as long
as possible but I'd like to be it's I'm
really more focused on health span I
want to be healthy I want that square
wave I want to you know I want to be
healthy healthy healthy and then gone I
don't want the long
Decay um but and I'm curious I want to
see how things turn out you know I'd
like to be here I love my my family and
my close friends and I want to I'm
curious about them and I want to see so
I have a lot of reasons to stay around
but
it's mortality doesn't doesn't have that
effect on me that it did you know maybe
when I was in my
20s well Jeff thank you for creating
Amazon one of the most incredible
companies in history and thank you for
trying your best to make humans and
multiplanetary species expanding out
into our solar system maybe Beyond to
meet the aliens out there and uh thank
you for talking today well Lex thank you
for uh doing your part to lengthen our
attention
spans appreciate that very
much